in a previous video we use the quotient
rule in order to find the derivatives of
tangent of X and cotangent of X and what
I want to do in this video is to keep
going and find the derivatives of secant
of X and cosecant of X so let's start
with secant of X the derivative with
respect to X of secant of X well secant
of X is the same thing as so we're going
to find the derivative with respect to X
of secant of X is the same thing as 1
over 1 over the cosine of X and that's
just the definition of secant and you
could there's multiple ways you could do
this when you learn the chain rule that
actually might be a more natural thing
to use to evaluate the derivative here
but we know the quotient rule so we will
apply the quotient rule here and it's no
coincidence that you to the same answer
the quotient rule actually can be
derived based on the chain rule and the
product rule but I won't keep going into
that let's just apply the quotient rule
right over here so this derivative is
going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to the derivative
of the top well what's the derivative of
1 with respect to X well that's just 0
times the function on the bottom so
times cosine of X cosine of X minus
minus the function on the top well
that's just 1 times the derivative on
the bottom well the derivative of the
bottom is derivative of cosine of X is
negative sine of X so we could put the
sine of X there but it's negative sine
of X so that you have a minus and it
would be a negative so we could just
make that a positive and then all of
that over the function on the bottom
squared so cosine of x squared and so 0
times cosine of X that is just 0 and so
all we are left with is sine of X over
cosine of x squared and there's multiple
ways that you could rewrite this if you
like you could say that this is the same
thing as sine of x over cosine of x
times 1 over cosine
X and of course this is tangent of x
times secant of X secant of X so you
could say derivative of secant X is sine
of X over cosine squared of X or it is
tangent of x times secant of X so now
let's do cosecant so the derivative with
respect to X of cosecant of X well
that's the same thing as the derivative
with respect to X of 1 over sine of X
cosecant is 1 over sine of X I remember
that because you think it's cosecant
maybe it's it's the reciprocal of cosine
but it's not it's the opposite of what
you would expect cosines reciprocal
isn't cosecant it is secant once again
opposite of what you were out of what
you would expect that starts with an S
this starts with the C that starts with
the C that starts with an S just the way
that it happened to be defined but
anyway let's just evaluate this once
again we'll do the quotient rule but you
could also do this using the chain rule
so it's going to be the derivative of
the expression on top which is zero
times the expression on the bottom which
is sine of X sine of X minus the
expression on top which is just 1 times
the derivative of the expression on the
bottom which is cosine of X all of that
over the expression on the bottom
squared sine squared of X that's 0 so we
get negative cosine of X over sine over
sine squared of X so that's one way to
think about it or if you like you could
view this the same thing we did over
here this is the same thing as negative
cosine of X or sine of X times 1 over
sine of X and this is negative cotangent
of X negative cotangent of X times let
me write this way
times 1 over sine of X is cosecant of X
cosecant cosecant of X so whichever one
you find more useful